and the shutdown is also affecting
airport screeners who have to keep
working without pay Kris Van Cleave is
at Washington Dragons National Airport
tracking the potential impact on air
safety Kris everyone is paying attention
to this closely
well good morning absolutely you know
the TSA leadership remains very
concerned about a potential tipping
point moment when screeners will look
elsewhere to pay their bills because you
know today they got a pay stub with zero
dollars on it and that could really make
it a lot harder to staff checkpoints
like the one behind me here it is
important to note that the vast majority
of TSA officers have been on the job
throughout the shutdown working without
pay but there has been a modest increase
in the number of sick calls compared to
last year
if staffing becomes an issue the TSA
will reduce the number of screening
lanes that will result in longer lines
and the very real potential of missed
flights Miami International Airport is
prepared to close terminal G in the
afternoons starting this weekend to free
up TSA officers to work busier
checkpoints in part due to sick calls
FAA air traffic controllers rallied on
Capitol Hill yesterday calling for an
end of the shutdown they're also on the
job working without pay one controller
posted this picture on Twitter of her
pay stub showing zero dollars the NTSB
can investigate fatal crashes right now
because it's investigators have been
furloughed and they can only bring them
back if there is a reasonable likelihood
of a life threatening safety issue be
honest unbelievable Chris so aside from
the inconvenience of longer lines if TSA
screeners don't show up for work is it
still safe to fly well so far the vast
majority have shown up to work if they
stop showing up to work you won't be
able to go through security and you
won't be able to fly but right now there
there's no talk of safety issues air
traffic controllers are on the job TSA
screeners are on the job it's safe to
fly all right thank you Chris could I
just say when I was at the airport last
week passengers were thanking the TSA
screeners for being being there on the
job you might want to think about that
when you're flying that's right people
are there without pay working one yeah
absolutely that's exactly right